If you want control over your UVs, you can actually control this through the material
editor as well.
So we can add a text quad using the U shortcut and you can drag and drop the text quad in
there, maybe set the UV tile into one and one.
And then we can also multiply that text quad to get some UV scaling going on.
And that will expose that parameter, which gives you a lot of functionality and control
over the UV.
And we can even add a custom rotator as well.
So again, custom rotator node is here and then we can divide that by whatever numerical
value, maybe it's 360 and then use UV rotate as one there to add a custom rotator.
So let's jump into the editor.
Let's get that set up.
Again, we're getting some more advanced functionality now over the material editor.
So in our material editor, we want the texture coordinate and maybe you want it on the albedo
texture for example.
So let's add a text quad.
We can do this holding U and left clicking.
So that's our texture coordinate.
We also want to multiply this texture coordinate, just making sure the UV tile is one and one.
Scroll down M to multiply.
So we'll multiply this and then we'll add a one and left click for a constant, convert
this to a parameter and let's go for UV scale on this one.
So UV scale, I'll set the default value to one on the UV scale.
There we go.
And then let's multiply this into the custom rotator.
We could add this directly in if we only just wanted to use the UV scale, but let's get
the custom rotator in here as well.
Let's do custom, custom rotator.
So we want to plug the UVs into here like that.
The rotated value that can then go into the UV there.
And now let's add the UV rotate.
So we'll hold down one and left click and convert to a parameter.
Again you start finding you're doing the same process over and over again, which is good
habit to get into.
So UV rotate, we'll do a one there and then we will divide this.
So we will divide and we'll make sure coordinate B is 360.
So divide that by 360 and then rotation can go into the rotation angle.
So now we can have control over the UVs, the scaling of the UVs.
If you want to give the grouping to these texture coordinates, you can.
So the UV scale and that I think would be four.
Yeah, that would be four.
And then we want to do rotate as well.
So that could be five.
So you can see things getting organized here, which is really nice.
Nice way to add some UV control over your albedo texture.
And of course you can do this for other textures.
You could drag it out into multiple outputs and copy that setup.
However you would like to then start authoring these materials.
So the first thing we want to do now and now that we got our material set up is to
actually give it a test drive and let's see how it's looking.
So let's go into our scene.
You can have any basic geometry.
You don't have to have this scene.
You could just have a cube if you wanted to from the shapes palette.
It can be anything you would like.
I'm just going to maybe scale it up as well.
So I'll create, I'll get the material instance and I will apply this to the mesh.
I can either plug it in here under the material or I can drag and drop it as well, whichever
one you'd prefer to, whichever approach you prefer to take.
And let's make sure we have our UV scale turned on and let's try and find some kind of rock
or some other type of texture.
Doesn't matter what texture it is, but just make sure you have some kind of texture going
on here.
I'm going to change this tint color here just to make sure that it's easier to see on the
screen.
Maybe I'll look at this here.
So we've got some kind of rock going on here.
Let's make sure this gets saved and updated.
Let's make sure we're in the lit mode as well.
So if you turned off the lighting previously, make sure you're in lit mode.
And now let's play around with some of these scale values.
So I'm just going to bring this into some kind of real estate that you can see.
So first of all, we've got the UV scale.
Again, I'm just trying to organize my window so you can see a little bit.
So let's scale it by two.
You can see it's scaling by two.
If I want it to repeat less, you can have a scale of 0.1.
And you can just keep scaling and scaling.
I think the larger you scale, you start to see the repeating patterns.
But you get the idea of the scale working.
And then UV rotate.
If you, I mean, we can see this happening in real time.
But if you want to type whatever values in, you can see that rotating.
So we know that our properties are working, which means we're in a really good place.
Maybe I want to save these values.
I'm not sure.
But I think the last thing I want to do is because we're going to be plugging normal
maps in and because we're going to be using certain textures, let's actually jump back
into the material.
And let's actually say this isn't just for the Albedo.
Let's say I'm going to drag the comments in here.
And I'm just going to drag down here and say hit comment and say, let's say, text texture
coordinate, something like that.
You can call it whatever you'd like.
But essentially what we want to do, maybe just add a bit of alpha just whilst we're
here or remove a bit of alpha.
But I think we want to do this for all the UVs because we're going to be using normal
maps and especially different texture maps.
You probably want to be, if you're scaling one, you probably more often than not want
to be doing all of them uniformly.
Now, if for whatever reason you don't, you can obviously just copy and paste that information.
But I think I'm going to plug that into all four in this instance.
And if I am doing that, I'm going to remove the group.
Well, maybe not remove the group, maybe add a five and text co-ord, something like that.
You can call the group whatever you'd like.
So I'll call, I'll set the priority of two for that.
And then I'll set the priority of one for this one.
And I'll save it.
And now in our material instance, we should be able to see these texture coordinate values
now here.
And again, we can scale it.
And this will mean that the normal map is scaling and the roughness maps or whatever
maps we're using, they're all being scaled uniformly, which I think is the desired result
that we'd want in this instance.
So yeah, hopefully that shows you a really nice power of the material editor and just
add in the customizable functionality of whatever you would like.
Again, how to save the materials, making sure you're consistently saving.
Just all these elements will help build out your material libraries.